[Musik]
und eine klimabilanz klimabilanz wie
soll ich denn leben aber mit
und wenn du jetzt deine wäsche anstatt
der 60 karten über 30 fest wird sie
genauso sauber und du verringert den
stromverbrauch um 65 prozent brutto spaß
sogar noch ein paar und diese dinger
hier sind echt was du glaubst entfern
selbst aus dabei frisst er immer weiter
strom macht deutschlandweit sowie co2
die zwei bis drei kohlekraftwerke im
jahr ausstoßen und ich
noch nicht abschalten wir haben doch
gerade erst angefangen
hoch oben im norden versteckt in der
dänischen ostsee wissen sie wie man das
macht energie einsparen und sie selber
klimaneutral erzeugen
die kleine dänische insel samsung ist
ein testlabor für die energiewende die
3700 einwohner haben erreicht was für
viele staaten utopie ist sie produzieren
mehr energie als sie verbrauchen und die
windräder gehören den bewohnern keinem
energiekonzern einer der ersten die vor
20 jahren investierten war groß landwirt
jürgen trainer berg ich mach das doch
nicht wegen des klimas ich mache das war
mir klar ist dass sich damit geld
verdienen kann und weil es ein gutes
gefühl ist das gut selber energie zu
erzeugen
dann brauchst du den mittleren osten
oder putin nicht nach ein bisschen gas
oder öl zu fragen ist es wirklich so
einfach
eine delegation japanischer pharma will
genau das wissen von jürgen ranneberg
unseren herman simm dem organisator der
energiewende auch samsung auch trainer
bergs gäste sind auf einer insel zu
hause auf ogata im norden japans
dort bauen sie reis an wie viele tonnen
reis produzierte auf einem hektar 35
ranneberg schlägt aus allem kapital auch
aussahen stroh das verkauft er an ein
heizkraftwerk für mich ist das sechs
tonnen stroh elf tonnen getreide
das sind ungefähr sieben tonnen öl pro
hektar wenn sie sich das stroh anschauen
die brauchen zwischen zweieinhalb und
drei kilo stroh für einen liter öl
dieselbe menge energie
und das stroh funktioniert wie eine
batterie wenn es kalt ist kann man das
verbrennen oder nicht dann lässt man es
einfach liegen
man nutze es genau dann wenn man es
braucht
und erzeugt im nächsten jahr einfach
neue
1997 wurde samsung als dänemarks energie
insel ausgewählt innerhalb von zehn
jahren sollten saubere energieträger die
selbstversorgung gewährleisten
die inselbewohner schaffen es in 8
40 millionen euro haben sie bisher in
erneuerbare energien investiert samsung
produziert heute viermal mehr energie
als es verbraucht
wenn wir vom klimawandel sprechen
dieses jahr hatten wir mehr regen als
jemals zuvor wir merken dass wir rekorde
brechen der nächste stopp ein
heizkraftwerk für 250 haushalte
betrieben mit strom
der grund für den wandel
wir wollen die örtliche wirtschaft
stärken es ging nicht um den eisbären in
der arktis das ist zweitrangig und dann
positiver nebeneffekt die hauptsache ist
wie können wir die energiewirtschaft vor
ort ändern
deswegen muss man die bürger davon
überzeugen dass sie davon profitieren
wenn sie investieren
das stroh wird gewechselt und über ein
förderband zum ofen transportiert das
dort erhitzte wasser versorgt dann über
ein rohrsystem die angeschlossenen
haushalte auch das abfallprodukt asche
findet verwendung als mineralien reicher
dünger für die landwirtschaft die
energie akademie jährlich kommen 5000
besucher um zu lernen wie man ohne
fossile brennstoffe auskommt dänemark
setzt bei der energiewende vor allem auf
windkraft fossile brennstoffe werden
besteuert
mit aktuell 23 euro pro tonne sören herr
mansen hat seit 20 jahren erfahrung mit
dem projekt wind und solaranlagen sind
technologien die sich auch schnell
wieder abbauen lassen haben zerstören
die natur nicht
vielleicht finden sie ein absehbarer
zeit etwas das noch besser funktioniert
das ist also nur ein schritt auf dem weg
zu mehr nachhaltigkeit
die energiewende zur bürgerwache machen
und so den lebensstandard verbessern
das hat auch samsung gut funktioniert
[Musik]
auch im kreis rhein hunsrück hat man die
energie wende schon geschafft ganz ohne
politik hier gibt es allein 280
windturbinen die erste davon haben
werner vogt und seine mitstreiter
aufgestellt das war 1995 wind pionier
voigt hat früh erkannt wie wichtig
bürgerbeteiligung ist
aus betroffenen beteiligte machen ist
fuchs credo 15 turbinen hat der
unternehmer so im hunsrück finanziert
die region rhein hunsrück galt lange als
strukturschwach heute nimmt sie eine
vorreiterrolle in der energiewende ein
junger menschen wie dominik vogt ziehen
zurück in die region
er will in die fußstapfen seines vaters
treten an die anfänge vor 25 jahren
erinnern sich beide noch gut fand ja
keiner was macht der da überhaupt war
das war ja völlig was völlig neues ich
habe heute das projekt vorgestellt und
hab halt leute gesucht die mitmachen die
halt ihr ihr geld halt in den wind
reinsetzen und bin ich halt über land
gezogen
für den wind freudige haben wir haben
hier das riesenglück dass unsere
generation keine kriege mitgemacht hat
alle unsere vorgänger generation hatten
aufbauarbeit zu leisten und wir haben
das glück dass es nicht ist aber wir
haben eine verantwortung gegenüber den
kindern dass wir diese wunderbare welt
die wir haben dass es erhalten und nicht
leichtfertig aufs spiel setzen
und das hat schon bei mir ganz früh
angefangen mit mit umweltschutz mit
naturschutz und ja einfach mein herz da
verschlägt wo von der politik für
absolut im stich gelassen
das einzige was passiert dass sie das
unnötigerweise nach hinten verschieben
und damit zeit verschenken wo wir das
klima noch retten können und das ist der
eigentliche skandal dran
der kreis rhein hunsrück macht auf
kommunalebene vor was auch
deutschlandweit möglich wäre wenn
politik und lokale macher an einem
strang ziehen wind und solarenergie
photovoltaik und biomasse produzieren
heute drei mal mehr strom als der
landkreis verbraucht das und viele
andere projekte haben die bürger hier
selbst finanziert und umgesetzt
und die entwicklung geht weiter besuch
im neuen groß batteriespeicher köthen
roth hier ist werner vogt mit dem man
verabredete im hintergrund die fäden
zieht klimaschutzmanager frank-michael
schlimmsten englischen pragmatismus was
die leute ja auszeichnet die werden
nicht probleme gesucht sondern die
lösungen
seit einem jahr ist der landkreis auch
testlabor für das intelligente stromnetz
der zukunft in grün rot haben bund und
energieversorger einen groß
batteriespeicher aufgestellt geleitet
von west netz mitarbeiter stefan ameling
und das herzstück unserer anlage ist
allerdings und sein portal container den
wir hier sehen
die 600 batterie module sollen helfen
die schwankenden energie- überschüsse zu
managen
wir haben haben viel wind jetzt haben
wir die möglichkeit dass wir den strom
da war auch erzeugt wird von den
umliegenden feldern sie ja ein speichern
können
dieser speicher hat jetzt kapazität von
4 megawatt stunden als vergleich mit
allein mit den modulen die jetzt hier
sind könnten sind 400 haushalte einen
tag lang versorgen sind gar nicht so die
riesenmengen die war wirklich hier ein
speichern möchten sondern wir möchten
vermeiden dass der strom der hier
erzeugt wird berg transportiert wird und
dadurch verluste entstehen wenn wir das
hier alles vor ort nutzen können da
brauchten wir die ganzen kassen nicht
mehr in dieser größenordnung geplant so
es ist die probieren momentan
kleinen aus was man später auf ganz
deutschland aus rollen kann
smart grid nennt sich das intelligente
stromnetz der zukunft im kreis rhein
hunsrück sind die weichen dafür schon
gestellt wie sein vater will auch
dominik vogt in die windenergie
einsteigen
trotz ungewisser zukunft
das schöne ist er habe überhaupt keine
wahl und das ist doch eigentlich ganz
gut so aber deswegen in dem haushalt
aufgewachsen wo das von anfang an gelebt
wurde und gemacht wurde und von daher
glaube ich also ist das einfach eine
grundeinstellung frage mich hinsetzen
darauf zu warten dass irgendjemand was
für uns macht vergiss es ja selber
aufstehen die dinge in die hand nehmen
den mut nicht verlieren einfach dafür
kämpfen dass wir so eine schöne welt
gewisse haben noch weiterhin gewissen
körpers ist alle energie in eine taste
wird
[Musik]